[Musique]
une autre nuit sous les bombes et les
roquettes
une centaine lancées depuis gaza vers
les villes d'ashkelon sderot et netivot
de la majorité ont été interceptés
certaines ont percé le ciel d'israéliens
à jaffa la nuit de michael attal a été
courte
on pensait que ça allait être une seule
salle hier à 21h et puis voilà 3h07 du
matin jusqu'à 3h30 9 sonnerie
répétitives avec je pense 110 roquettes
qui ont été tirées sur la sur la région
plutôt israël avait bombardé un immeuble
de gaza
une tour qui abrite les locaux de la
chaîne de la télévision al-aqsa
l'organisation hamas a confirmé la mort
de six membres de sa branche armée
gaza ziad medoukh y vit depuis 25 ans il
a choisi de rester et à chacune des
violences qui ont émaillé ce conflit
il vit la même chose je suis horrifié
avec les maisons font surtout compter ce
soir mais maintenant on fait semblant de
les calmer l'armée israélienne a déployé
ses troupes militaires le long de la
bande de gaza dans un message vidéo le
colonel en charge de l'administration de
l'enclavé affirme que les gazaouis et le
prix des tentatives du hamas de
renforcer sa position mais les
affrontements traîne désormais des
allures de lynchage cette nuit des
militants d'extrême droite non loin de
tel-aviv se sont fait justice eux mêmes
en s'attaquant un homme arabe
des images insoutenables diffusée sur
une chaîne publique la veille dans la
ville mixte judéo-arabe de l'aude des
jeunes arabes ont mis le feu à une
synagogue en débat
de ce fait tous ceux qui sont derrière
cette violence arrêtez les mettez les en
prison y laisser les arabes et les juifs
continuent à vivre ensemble ici tout
était parfait il ya dix ans renchérit
sept habitants arabes de l'aude
il commence à y avoir de l'animosité des
provocations des deux côtés l'état
d'urgence est d'ailleurs décrété dans la
ville
la nouvelle flambée de violence la plus
intense depuis sept ans a fait plus
d'une soixantaine de morts des deux
côtés
les etats unis ont fermement condamné
les tirs de roquettes par hamas ni le
secrétaire d'état ajoute que la perte de
civils est une tragédie un émissaire et
dépêché immédiatement dans la région
malgré les bombardements les offensives
les roquettes et les violences ziad
medoukh et michaela talent continue de
croire qu'une paix est possible
les deux populations sont victimes de
cette situation là chacune de son côté
victimes pour pour sa propre maison
cossue au même non plus au régime une
solution militaire les chiffres ont une
paix fragile qui éloigne encore
davantage la solution à deux états les
départs la communauté internationale
depuis des années ici à sneek rails at
radio canada montréal